now out of all the cancers that someone
can get
pancreatic cancer
is definitely one you want to avoid and
you want to prevent so it's really
important to understand
some information about the pancreas
because pancreatic cancer
is aggressive
and by the time you know you have it a
lot of times it's spread
to other organs
and it's uh
almost impossible to reverse
so first let's go through the signs and
symptoms and then we'll talk about what
the pancreas does
and some other things that can help you
avoid cancer of the pancreas now the
number one or top symptoms are very very
vague and non-specific to the pancreas
so you wouldn't normally associate
those symptoms with the pancreas at all
because they're number one weight loss
number two loss of appetite now a lot of
you watching have done the ketogenic
diet and you've lost weight and you lost
your appetite that's completely
different we're talking about a person
who's doing nothing to their diet no
changes and all of a sudden out of the
blue they start losing weight and they
just lose their appetite that's when you
need to be aware of like something's not
right other symptoms would be general
fatigue
upper abdominal pain that radiates to
your back usually on the left side up
here also it could be around the back
part which is opposite to the pancreas
which is kind of like a right in the
middle of the lower chest area slightly
to the left that's where the pancreas is
it's right underneath the stomach so you
can have pain there as well your pain
also increases when you eat food okay
we'll talk about why that is
you might have bloating you might feel
nauseous you might have symptoms that
you're not digesting well which we're
going to talk about why that is and your
stool could be loose it could be kind of
greasy
bad smelling leave skid marks inside the
toilet bowl so all of these are signs
and symptoms that you could potentially
have pancreatic cancer but it could also
be other problems with the pancreas
pancreatitis it could be something else
called an exocrine insufficiency where a
certain part of the pancreas that makes
enzymes is not producing enzymes we'll
talk about that it can also be
inflammation of the pancreas that's
caused because of the certain
bile ducts and the pancreatic ducts are
blocked from
sludge so it may be a stone but it may
not be a stone it could be very very
thick
bile material
because the bile material that's going
through these ducks are a combination of
cholesterol and bile so you have to have
the right ratio to make it flow if you
don't have enough bile
the cholesterol sludge becomes thick and
then it creates a
pressure in the ducts and that backs up
in the pancreas and that can cause the
pancreatitis
what happens when you obstruct the flow
of the pancreas of things coming out
like the digestive juices some of these
enzymes can actually start to digest
the pancreas itself so your body is
digesting itself and that that's
creating the inflammation
other causes of pancreatitis would be
alcohol that's a big one or
diabetes
now let me just kind of explain what the
pancreas does so you can kind of wrap
your wits around this i'm going to try
to do it in a really simple way
the pancreas is interesting because you
have two different types of glands
that exist in an organ
so we have this pancreatic organ
that's composed of two different types
of glands so you have the endocrine part
that's the hormone part so the pancreas
makes hormones and then the other part
is another type of gland called the
exocrine part and the exocrine part
makes the enzymes most of the pancreas
is exocrine okay like 97 of it so um it
produces a lot of enzymes like
per day it might produce like eight
ounces of enzymes to help you digest
food we're talking about enzymes to help
break down carbohydrates
fats with the help of bile of course
and
proteins okay
and so every time you eat the pancreas
has to predict what you're eating and
get ready and make these enzymes and
then release them at the right time as
the food comes from the stomach and the
small intestine so the purpose of the
enzymes is to allow you to extract
nutrients and fuel from the food that
you eat now the exocrine part of the
pancreas also releases other things too
one being
something called bicarbonate now you
probably know a baking soda that's
sodium bicarbonate well this is similar
it's just a bicarbonate that helps
neutralize
uh the acids coming down from the
stomach because
normally the small intestine should be
slightly alkaline and the stomach should
be very very
majorly
acid so we don't want that strong acid
to put a hole in the small intestine as
it's coming through
so your pancreas helps out and it
adjusts the acid to make it the right ph
and a lot of these enzymes are activated
when there's a certain ph whether it's
alkaline or acid so if there's some
problem with your digestive system and
the ph isn't right
these enzymes don't even get activated
because the ph is what activates them so
the bicarbonates are very very important
so what you have to understand is the
stomach is extremely extremely acid okay
and the small intestine is just slightly
alkaline so it's just if you look at the
relationship between the two it's it's
pretty dramatic
and this is why when you take baking
soda or an antacid where you alkalize
the stomach because you're drinking all
this alkaline water you have to realize
that you're diluting the stomach which
is normally supposed to be very very
acidic so it can create major problems
because at the very start of your
digestion you need that
strong acid you don't want it to be
alkaline because then we actually
stop the release of enzymes in the
stomach like the ones that help you
digest protein
and now we have
undigested protein going into the small
intestine now what is that going to do
with the pancreas
it has to work like crazy to release
more and more enzymes to try to make up
the damage and do the work that the
stomach was supposed to do
so it's really important to keep the
stomach really really acid and then
allow the pancreas to release the
enzymes it needs to as well as the
bicarbonates at the right time so
bicarbonates are alkaline okay so that's
what they are now we also have another
part of the pancreas called the
endocrine part and that's where all the
hormones are made they're made in these
little these cells okay and they're
scattered throughout the pancreas
and
we have certain cells that make insulin
which is about seventy percent of all
those um endocrine glands um seventy
percent is insulin okay and then we have
other cells that make uh another hormone
called glucagon and that kind of does
the opposite of insulin so if we look at
insulin and we look at glucagon so
insulin has everything to do with
storing glucose okay and also
reducing blood sugars so it takes
glucose out of the cell and it also puts
it into storage
as stored sugar in your liver and your
muscles called glycogen and then when
you have too much glucose it'll then
convert the glucose into fat cells okay
and also it converts it into cholesterol
and the fat is triglycerides okay so
insulin is a storage hormone then we
have glucagon
glucagon does the opposite it actually
releases that stored glucose
and once you do that it releases fat for
energy so
insulin is triggered when you eat
and mainly carbohydrates
but also somewhat
protein
but believe it or not it's not triggered
by fat or fiber then we have glucagon
that's triggered when you don't eat so
when you're fasting it's also triggered
when you're not eating sugar and you're
eating protein so a certain amount of
protein will be triggered by glucagon so
we have an interesting thing with
protein because both insulin and
glucagon is triggered by protein so you
have both of these hormones whereas
glucose
only triggers insulin now some other
things that will release glucagon would
be
i already mentioned protein
exercise is one
i already mentioned fasting and so
glucagon is all about
extracting energy from
stored glucose
or stored energy as fat and then we have
some additional cells
called somostatin and that has
everything to do with
satisfying your hunger and so if you're
hungry you're going to stop eating so
it's kind of a it's an inhibitory
hormone it kind of stops certain things
from happening
and
then we have two additional hormones
okay we have somatosatin
and another one called pancreatic
polypeptide now don't get caught up with
the names just realize that these two
hormones um
help to inhibit uh the other two
hormones it's kind of like they're kind
of like the brake pads and so they're
going to increase
your feeling satisfied after you eat so
then you stop eating and they're also
going to help you decrease the enzyme
action so they kind of completed the
digestion as far as the pancreas goes
because at some point after the pancreas
done its job we have to have something
to stop these chemical reactions from
occurring so they inhibit things so they
make you satisfied they help you get rid
of your hunger they basically suppress
the
gastrointestinal process okay they kind
of suppress the actions
so basically you have a couple hormones
involved when you're eating and then you
stop eating and then also some other
hormones to help complete that digestion
and inhibit
things that happen in that area of your
body
some real interesting things that you
should know about number one
when you
constantly
increase insulin
because you're eating frequently or
you're doing a lot of carbs and
you develop insulin resistance and then
eventually you develop
pre-diabetes and then eventually you
develop diabetes okay
um diabetics um start to have a
atrophied pancreas so if you're diabetic
the pancreas starts to get smaller okay
and some other things happen too you
start to get destruction of both
gland
parts of the pancreas
so diabetes really is just a dysfunction
of the
glands in your pancreas so for example
diabetes type 1 is the destruction of
the cells that produce insulin and even
type 2 is a major dysfunction of the
cells that make insulin but also and
this is what a lot of people don't
realize that insulin does greatly affect
the enzyme production of the pancreas
okay so the extra can part of the
pancreas is significantly affected this
is why diabetics
over time
have a lot of digestive problems they
cannot extract the fat soluble vitamins
that well from the food they eat so they
become deficient in vitamin a which they
need for the eyes vitamin e for the
heart
vitamin k
vitamin d
and so all of these vitamins are going
to be on the low side because the
enzymes are not released that well and
so diabetics get
bloating they have a lot of oxidation
and free radical damage going on because
of the glucose that is uncontrolled they
have a lot of inflammation in the
pancreas okay
and that can lead to cancer as well as
fibrosis so you can see that when you
have diabetes it doesn't just affect
the endocrine part of the gland infects
the entire gland which includes
digestion and the enzymes that are
released
and if we take a look at cancer
cancer occurs because there's damage to
the mitochondria and this damage can
occur from
chronic
inflammation
and again insulin could be responsible
for that diabetics have a much higher
risk of getting pancreatic cancer than
other types of conditions
and also if we take a look at uh
pre-diabetic what what comes before that
insulin resistance the great majority of
the population has insulin resistance so
they're kind of headed in this direction
and so this is why
going on the ketogenic diet the healthy
version of the ketogenic diet so you're
also including a lot of high density
nutrition
foods with antioxidants
good amounts of vegetables with the
vitamins and minerals and
and things like that
are all really important so you can
avoid getting cancer and then we have
intermittent fasting which gives the
pancreas a chance to
heal and reset so it doesn't have to
constantly work and
out of all the things that will drop
inflammation it's the fasting that will
do it the fastest no pun intended so the
big take from this video uh that you
should get is that there's one big huge
problem that keto in intermittent
fasting
helps you correct and it's insulin
resistance which is at the heart of
diabetes and that's what really causes
you to go into diabetes it's kind of
like the first condition that occurs
before pre-diabetes and then diabetes so
out of all the actions
that you could do to avoid pancreatic
cancer and of course i'm assuming you
don't smoke or drink a lot or you're not
being exposed to chemicals things like
that is the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet with intermittent fasting
so i hope you have more information on
the pancreas but i really want you to
watch this video on the relationship
between inflammation
and cancer check it out i put it right
here
you